- Can you go buy a five
to $700 pair of sneakers
so I can give
them away right away?
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you this was the
last Monday
morning of your life?
Hair and make up time.
Planet of the Apps, Wendi.
We gonna do it right?
- Always right.
Here we go.
First Instagram Live.
Hello, Instagram Live.
What's up guys?
Let's see what's going on.
Here we go, here they come.
Super excited about it.
The Instagram Live.
DRock catching the
moment and there it is.
Rose O'Hara you're the
first person ever to comment.
Big love. I'm gonna
see if I can click you.
Nope. Pin, oh yeah, I can.
That's cool.
Let me pin.
Gonna pin that Rose.
There you are Rose O'Hara.
Rose O'Hara the first one ever.
You're live.
- [Man] 'Sup?
Hey, what's going on, guys?
- [Gary] How do you
feel about being live?
- [Man] Great man.
It's cool dude. First timer.
- [Gary] Alright.
Do I need to work?
Am I supposed to be working?
- It'd be nice if
you got to work, please.
- Alright, Shaan.
- [Shaan] This is you.
- [Gary] You're watching.
- Yes.
- [Gary] This is very meta.
- [Shaan] This is super meta.
- [Gary] Super meta.
Oh, it's got a
nice little delay.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You'll be
showing up soon, Shaan.
- Oh, that's exciting.
- [Gary] Let's see this.
Walking over, it's a nice
solid like 15, 20 seconds.
- Yep.
- [Gary] Shaan, you're coming.
Here you come.
- Yep.
- [Gary] You're
about to show up.
- Full body zoom on this too.
- [Gary] Look at this.
- Cameras in a
camera in a camera.
- I think we're about to break
Instagram Live with this meta.
Are we ready to film?
- Yeah.
- Alright, filming Planet
of the Apps which is amazing.
Enjoying it,
'predicate all your guys love.
60 Second Club,
huge shout out to you guys.
Thank you so much for all of
you that shared the
"One Life" video. Right?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- [Gary] Loved it.
I appreciate that.
Lotta fun.
I'll be back on
soon on Instagram Live.
Today's the big day for that.
Can't wait to meet you too, Cam.
Brunch Back, great to see you.
Hey, Luis Miguel everybody wants
15 minutes and I'm giving them
away on the 60 Second Club so
make sure you're a part of it.
This is cool,
I agree. I agree.
HeavenLOL what?
I love it.
See you guys, love you.
Gotta go film.
("Don't" by Rei Topal)
So something that has been on my
mind and I wanted to make a
quick video about is I've been
reading so many of the
comments social networks about
these teenagers,
these kids, they don't get it.
They're always on their phone.
You know, I'm blown
away by the establishment,
by parents, by the market,
by the elders and
even by some of the
kids within the age demo
of the gross underestimation of
this 11 to 16-year-old,
this 10 to 19-year-old demo.
What world do you think they're
gonna be living in in 2025?
And so all these critiques you
have about what they're doing
and they're not socially this
and they're not good enough and
they don't work hard enough.
I don't know what
you're paying attention to.
Watching these kids grind and
hustle and create content and
ideas and businesses
in these social networks.
Why don't you shut the fuck up
and go to Instagram for three
hours and stop judging and pay
attention to the explosion of
this creative hustler class
that is the teenagers and the
dominant leaders of our future.
Probably not.
I'm here only tomorrow and I fly
back to New York Wednesday but
truth is seeing you right after
it at CES or talking during that
time when I'm done relaxing for
a few minutes like thrilled to
catch up before the end
of the year with a call.
There's no reason to
create any friction, go.
Do your thing.
There's no reason.
I know you would.
No reason, go do your thing.
Love you. See ya.
Alright, uh-huh, 100%.
I figured, okay cool.
Bye-bye.
Hey guys Gary Vaynerchuk but you
know that because I'm targeting
you pretty aggressively right
now with this video on Facebook.
I have a new book coming out
next year called "Crushed It."
It is going to feature people
that read the book "Crush It!"
and accomplished things.
Built businesses because of it.
Made their lives better.
Who?
- [Tyler] A dude named Sunny.
- Sunny.
- [Tyler] Motivational alarm.
- You got it.
- Sunny, what's up man?
It's GaryVee, wake the fuck up.
It's time to get up.
One life, baby.
You are literally
so God damn lucky.
It is literally
insane to be a human.
400 trillion to 1 and you're
trying to take a snooze button.
Get the fuck out of here.
Get up and crush it.
- [Tyler] Love that.
- I got motivated by that.
Guys, I'm gonna be in
the Dublin Tech Summit
February 15th to 16th
and to be very honest,
it's going to be the only time
I'm probably going to
be in Ireland this year.
So come out, hear the thunder.
I'm gonna be tied up too but
we'll definitely talk before the
end of the day.
Alright, love you, man.
Talk to you later.
Bye-bye.
I'm in Seattle, Sid.
I can't wait to
see you who wins.
It was you.
You won.
Find me in
Seattle, baby. Congrats.
Put a ton of champagne emojis.
Champagne.
- [DRock] Champagne.
- Champagnes.
Alright, I just did the big
giveaway and we gave away the
winner as I was
promoting yesterday,
the 60 Second Club
which has been a lot of fun.
Jesus, 1500, 1800
people live in like one second.
2000, bang. 3100, Ty.
- Tychmitt5 Snapchat.
(group laughter)
- 3200, Ty.
- [DRock] The plug,
the plug, the plug.
Yeah, I'll be like five
minutes. Matt, hold on.
Are you willing to tell these
3500 people that we have to meet
right now and you
want to kill my livestream?
- Absolutely not.
Can you go buy a five to $700
pair of sneakers so I can give
them away right away?
- Yes.
- Like today or tomorrow night.
I feel like you can
do that right now, right?
- Yeah.
- Guys, let's
clap it up for Phil.
Say, "Thanks, Phil."
Alright, yeah so I want to
give away an
expensive pair of sneakers.
I want to give away some Yeezys
so that's what I'm gonna give
away later today or tomorrow.
You're finding,--
- I'm trying to find--
- find me in Seattle
to see what he wanted.
Find me in Seattle if
you're watching right now.
Let us know.
There's what's going on here.
Get me an $800, is $800 a good
number for a pair of sneakers?
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- There we go.
- [Tyler] The Fukijamas.
- [Gary] The Fukijamas.
- Depends on the
size but give me a range.
- [Gary] Give me some ranges,
we're going gift
certificate up in this bitch.
Oh, by the way, yeah
I drink coffee once in a while.
Is this the coffee?
I'm drinking this right now.
I use coffee as a comfort food.
I probably end up drinking,
what do you guys actually think
I drink in a day?
- [DRock] Three cups.
- Good $750. 750.
Get me a 750.
I think I drink two
cups of coffee a day.
- [DRock] I think three.
- Three?
What do you think?
- [Tyler] Total?
- It depends on
the day. Not a lot.
Yeah, I'm giving out shoes,
tell 'em I'm giving out shoes.
Say something
motivational for a college kid.
Man, Parthip, there're so many
things running through my mind.
Patience, opportunity,
the 400 trillion to 1 of
actually being a human being.
Like all the good
stuff that's going on.
It's just incredible.
It's incredible
how good we have it.
Look what's going on right now.
We're just hanging out
on the livestream engaging.
If fucking Keyshawn Johnson or
Macho Man Randy Savage did this
for me back in the day,
I woulda lost my fucking mind.
You know?
You're dynamic, Benji.
New book's coming out
Geno probably January of '18.
I'll be writing
it all next year.
You inspire me back, Daymond.
Love the
engagement on Twitter lately.
Yeah, I'm really, Ryan,
this whole 60 Second Club thing,
you know it's just, it's driving
deep in to the
community, like deep.
Daily DailyVees.
You know, DRock is here.
Alright let's do a quick
little something with the 3700.
I need old-school,
Phil you're too young for this.
Age, sex, location.
- A.S.L?
- A.S.L? No, you
guys did that, too?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You youngsters, alright.
Let's do it. Ooh, I can comment.
A.S.L? Let's do it.
A.S.L? Bang!
Where you from?
Who are you?
What up?
The engagement, you
can't find 'em, right?
So that means
he's gonna get his own.
See if he can do custom.
See if he's replied there.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah.
- If he didn't put it in there
then we're gonna customize it.
He won the big giveaway
so we'll see what he wants.
Trinidad, baby, I love it.
Germany in the house.
Brazil.
Dunk you're not 12
male in New York City.
Dunk, Dunk's a piece of work.
We can't rewind this, right?
There's no rewinding, no saving.
- [DRock] There's no saving.
- That's why DRock
is saving it right now.
Alright.
Five, ten more minutes so
let's do a custom #AskGaryVee.
Are we gonna call people?
- You wanna?
- I think that's how I want
The #AskGaryVee Show.
I've decided to change the
The #AskGaryVee Show into a
call in show that happens
where the numbers get put up.
I'm gonna do a post, actually,
can you hit up Tyler right now?
No, no, can you hit up
Tyler, Other Tyler--
- Yep.
- and tell him I need a call to
action post of #AskGaryVee show
is live now post your phone
number and that's what we'll do.
Now taking calls
for The #AskGaryVee,
however he wants to word it.
- Yep.
- Fuck with that.
Can you speak at a college?
Ha, Scooter Braun giving
me a "You're very sexy."
Scooter, Scooter, listen, since
you are the manager of Yeezy and
Bieber and
Ariana's back, I think,
Scooter, can you please
answer in the comments here.
Are you willing
to sign me Scooter?
Are you willing to sign me?
Guys, there's 3600 of you.
The most famous music manager in
the world is in here giving me
love but I want to sign me.
Let's go, Scooter.
(DRock chuckles)
Sign it up.
Put your money
where your mouth is.
What's your,--
- Bang, found him.
- You found him?
What does he want?
- He wants to
spend a day with you.
- Spend a day?
- Yep.
- Where is he?
- Right here.
Find me in Seattle.
- Show me.
There he is.
- I'm ready for tomorrow.
- Alright, he won.
Spend a day.
- Spend a day with GaryVee.
- Alright so from,
there's my yes.
March 18th.
Guys, if you ever want to know
where I'm speaking publicly it
is always on my website,
GaryVaynerchuk.com.
Oh, Scooter answered.
Probably said no,
I mean, I can't sing for shit.
(Gary mumbles lyrics)
I wish I could sing.
Guys, Scooter's the best.
First of all, he's hustler.
He's a golden hearted assassin.
That's like the Honey Empire.
He does his shit.
He loves his family.
He's a good man.
A lot of people
talk it, he does it.
I do like the new
J Cole. You don't like it?
- [DRock] I love it.
- I love it, too.
- I listened to
it over the weekend.
Mads.
- Hi, Gar.
- [Gary] What do you
got to say to the community?
- Love having Gary here.
- No, no, don't PR.
Talk about your life.
What'd you do this weekend?
- We had an awesome
holiday party on Friday.
- No, stop PR'ing.
I mean Saturday and Sunday.
- And then Bobby,
our studio guy,
held a ugly sweater
party which was awesome.
- Okay.
- And I got to wear an ugly
sweater so that was the best.
- Okay, good.
Fuck the Pats.
Otherwise I'll
see you guys later.
We'll keep doing stuff.
Love you, see you,
love you, see ya,
love you, see ya.
That's gonna be
fun to look at one day.
This is gonna be a fun
photo in like 10, 15 years.
You know?
("Malibu" by Rei Topal)
- What? I was
sneaky on this one, right?
- [DRock] Mhmmm.
- I was trying to be sneaky.
I would look for
you and I was like eh.
Shit, there was a
reason I was coming on here.
Fuck, I forgot.
What the fuck did
I want to talk about?
Oh, let's show them.
There's the proof.
So, The
#AskGaryVee Show, no, no,
I don't want to go live.
Not going live now.
Take that middle out.
What I want to do is post,
people post their number on
Instagram and then I go
to this and we film the show.
I don't want to do it live.
I want to do it as a
call in show recorded.
Like what we did in episode 106.
- [Tyler] Mhmmm.
But it's not going
to be #AskGaryVee Show?
- It's gonna be
The #AskGaryVee Show and
so I would call somebody.
Somebody give me
their number right now.
Is this thing not calling?
(phone ringing)
Oh, there we go.
- [Jessica] Hello,
this is Jessica.
- Hey Jessica,
it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Jessica] Hey Gary,
how are you?
- I'm well.
How are you?
- [Jessica] Good, good.
This is cool.
I'm glad it worked.
- It did work.
So you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
What's your question?
- [Jessica] So, I have
a question about selling.
- Okay.
- [Jessica] I have a (cutting
out) products that we make for
mindful living and religion.
- Okay.
- [Jessica] And it's
difficult to take the leap
to get people to buy.
I do a pretty good job of
building relationships with my
customers over social media.
- Mhmmm.
- [Jessica] And I
am selling a bit but
I just want to
talk (cutting out).
- Are you in a weird spot?
You chopped on me a little bit.
I couldn't fully hear that.
- [Jessica] Okay, can
you hear me okay now?
- Yeah, it's better.
What was the last part?
I'm selling a little bit but?
- [Jessica] But I'd just like
to see what I could do to really
amp up the motivation
to buy the product.
- From--
- [Jessica] I think
I'm doing a good job of it.
- You mean converting the social
audience at a higher level?
- [Jessica] Yes.
- So, do you have a sense
if you're converting at a good
level to begin with?
Do you know how you're doing
compared to people with similar
sized audiences that are
trying to sell them something?
- [Jessica] I think I'm
doing pretty well from all of
the research that
I've been doing.
I generally do about 1-2%
or something like that.
- That's pretty high.
So the other question and this
is gonna be the hardest question
I'm gonna ask you but I need you
to answer the truth or you're
not gonna get to the
place you want to be.
Which is are you building an
audience on social because you
then want to sell them to them?
Or basically the key, right?
And the reason I've done so
well is I think people have not
interpreted Jab, Jab,
Jab, Right Hook well enough.
Jab, Jab, Jab
Right Hook means
give, give, give and
then ask versus
then expect to get.
- [Jessica] Right,
I see what you're saying.
- You see where I'm going?
And I don't think there's
anything wrong with you building
an audience with
the expectation
of them buying something.
I just think that when you're
giving away free content or all
the other stuff you're
doing before you do a post where
you're asking them to buy,
if the energy and the soul and
the seed and the intent of that
free content is really quite in
a place where it's just there as
a proxy 'cause what you really
want to do is
sell them something,
you will not be as successful.
The reason
everybody that follows me,
buys my books,
well not everybody.
The reason I do well in selling
my books once every two years is
because outside of
sharing my content,
I don't ask for
anything in return.
Even with Wine Library TV
I never cared if
anybody bought the wine.
I don't care if
anybody buys my book. Right?
- [Jessica] Right.
- I have a business called
VaynerMedia that is running and
making my money,
speaking, investing.
My money is not predicated
on just monetizing my
social network and
everybody feels that, right?
So the reason I have
the community I have,
the reason when I do 60 Second
Club and things of that nature,
the reason I'm over-indexing
is because I'm not expecting
anything in return.
I don't care at all
if TigerWanNYC ever
buys anything from me.
I don't care if SashaSabari
ever buys anything from me.
Right, I'm not creating content
for the purpose of making
RyanANC or
KinicaMan or Wayne Barber.
I don't want
any of these people,
I don't feel like I'm doing it
where I think I'm the
reverse of the market.
I think people are putting out
content but what they're really
waiting for is the
sale and so then their jabs,
or their other content, has less
oomph against it and where they
put all their real energy
and heart is against the sale.
I'm the reverse.
I put so much oomph on bringing
value to the community around
the subject matter and then sure
when I want to sell something
I'm in book
promotion world, fine.
Sure, do I want everybody who's
watching me on Instagram Live
right now, the 2100 people to
screen shoot it and post it and
tell their community about me so
I can pick up one more person so
that I can help them?
Of course but I don't expect it.
And when I think
you make that religious,
emotional and mental shift you'd
be stunned by how
much higher you convert.
Because what will happen by
proxy is you'll start giving
more when you're actually giving
which will then allow you to
convert more when
you're actually asking.
- [Jessica] Right,
I see what you're saying.
No, that makes sense.
- And so I think that if you,
do you see where I'm going?
If you're actually,
actually trying to help people.
So, I'm trying to get people to
understand my world of business
and hustle but I don't need them
to buy my book or anything else.
I don't need anything from them
and then they trust me more and
then they have a bigger
impact and so what happens is,
do you know how frustrating it
is I give away all my free stuff
and then they go buy somebody's
bullshit course for like $700.
- [Jessica] (laughs) Right.
- Because they're
missing the point. Right?
They're looking for
another way to not do.
All I'm about is doing.
So what I would tell
you is do me a favor,
try to go the next
month putting out content,
doing live,
putting out white papers,
putting out, doing
Q&amp;As, doing giving.
Giving, giving, giving.
Don't ask for anything and then
ask and feel proud about that
and see what happens.
- [Jessica] Okay, I will.
- Awesome.
- [Jessica] Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome.
Have a great day and thanks for
calling The #AskGaryVee Show.
Alright, that's
that's what I want to do.
We'll film that and
that'll be the show.
It's a call in radio show.
- [Tyler] Mhmmm.
- Right?
Instead of a livestream.
- [Tyler] Yeah.
- Alright, what did
you guys think about that?
Give me the feedback.
Give me some feedback.
Are you guys looking for me?
Is Planet of the Apps
looking for me?
- [Tyler] Not sure.
- Yeah, I'm gonna do a whole new
thing so I'm gonna go with kind
of, oh, this would be
really cool for DailyVee.
Right, to see
my thought process.
It's gonna be like, "Hey guys,
I just posted on Instagram to
"get your phone number.
This is live #AskGaryVee."
Right?
And then I'll explain it
and then we'll go into it.
("Malibu" by Rei Topal)
Hey everybody.
I just posted an Instagram
post for your phone number.
This is the first
call in #AskGaryVee Show.